[Music]
it's got some stuff folks yo kids will
shoot no he give it together watches
wide open three let me just get a layup
yo kitch take the three no slang it into
the corner Murray's walk it open it he
throws it
he saw Murray in the corner he almost
like faked it to the wing and hooked it
to the corner a little high die action
Scottie got a two guard on you're big
[Applause]
one of the best assists of the year you
have to have the gift and Nicola Yogesh
certainly hasn't got great time
southeast
[Applause]
this at night
yo kids has great vision and drilling
for a big guy both can pass the
basketball
lukkage has the rebound behind the back
how do you say spectacular in Serbia a
lot of attention to hand they got the
stick
[Applause]
okay wait behind the bag two bees one
dribble finishes back Sydney has eyes in
the back of his head he does double
figures in pilot of 12
Benny can do that with the one hander
just a heads up play that's where you
know you're G once he knows where its
teammates it's not about looking at
until he's already tapped
oh good screen by Yogi's just buried
that is behind the back to Chandler
Devine the head pass boat as sweet as it
gets Nicola Yogi's doing his thing
[Applause]
oh my goodness were you looking were you
looking oh my goodness I mean that's
like Pete Maravich stuff